all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to morning coffee thoughts where
I give my thoughts over morning coffee
if you guys hear a little pitter patter
that's cuz my dog is with me today and
she's kind of slow okay so today I'm
going to talk about how I came up with
the hash em challenge so on Twitter I
have a challenge where I #
deem outfits appropriate or inappro
apprpriate for a wife and a mother now
many of you thinking Pearl just mind
your own business
Pearl Pearl why do you need to do this
now what inspired me to do this I'll
tell you some of you guys look so stupid
and nobody's here to tell you how stupid
you look some of you guys have
children and you're taking thirst traps
on Instagram I don't even care if you're
single what the
now look guys I give the I give the
single women a little bit more of a
leeway now it's not
because it's not because I I think that
single women should dress like hookers
but you know they're trying to catch a
man and they're young usually it's like
you know maybe they're young enough to
not know better but some of you are in
full-blown relationships
fullblown full-blown you you you're in
marriages with kids and your
Instagrams look like hookers
now many of you will say pearl but
Pearl
Pearl but
you you should just mind your own
business well I could but you know my
kids have to grow up with their
kids um so it's
like I mean if no one says anything then
we have these people that are just like
half naked walking around everywhere you
guys look ridiculous you you look like
clowns you guys have like a full face of
makeup and it's not even like light
makeup it's like it looks like I could I
could peel off a clown mask that's how
thin it thick it is then you have you're
in these sexual poses as a wife and a
mother and then you have naked pictures
on
Instagram um why do I have to open my
timeline and see all these naked
all the
time I'll even I'll even I'll be so nice
I'll even let you guys have like a
tasteful
like oneoff picture every now and then
but for some of you it's like every
single day and then the girls get all
mad at me like they're special I mean
none of you are special I just see you
on Twitter or Instagram or whatever it
is
um posting booty shots in a relationship
you guys look ridiculous you look so
stupid and nobody all these simps all
these simps are going to tell you that
you look fine all of these other women
are going to
say oh there's nothing wrong with what
you're doing you look great that's what
they're going to tell you and I'll be
the bad guy because I point out that you
guys look like high-end hookers not even
highend honestly sometimes hookers dress
less
promiscuous than some of you guys do on
here and then I'll come to find out
you're married or in a
relationship
why
why like the amount of dis respect and
we grow up in this
culture that tells us that's perfectly
okay there's nothing wrong with that and
I don't
care
um I I don't care if I look like the bad
guy for pointing out that this is
ridiculous so ladies yeah you guys look
like
clowns um let me know what you think
that's how I came up with the ID
challenge don't shoot the messenger and
I don't really care if you do um because
there's something about women that dress
with a level of sophistication in
class and it's much better than women
that dress like hookers thank you
welcome to my TED talk I'll talk to you
guys next time